[Music]
fella I've got to know how much are you
relating to this character she's very
different from me and she has very
different mindsets about things than I
do so it's kind of fun to go back and
forth and kind of like I take things
from page all the time now she's trying
to figure out dating and dealing with
the pressures of Hollywood is that
something that when you're seeing that
through her eyes you're having your own
flashback yeah I mean dating in
Hollywood is literally the worst thing
it gets really crazy because people make
it very difficult like if I'm get photos
out with somebody like it immediately
I'm their girlfriend and I moved in with
them too and I'm like what like do I
even call attention to this and say like
hello this is not true or do I just like
let it go because it's all just so
ridiculous mumble jumble people are
really crazy on socials and the way that
they're like you know unfortunately I
date people that have like you know
girls are like the girls that are in
love with them literally like I was
getting death threats people are hating
on me so hardcore I was like wow you
guys like are you serious right now and
you know and people think it doesn't
hurt but let me tell you okay it does
hurt and it doesn't feel good to read
this about yourself online even when you
know it's not true it can be really
hurtful and you really start to like
think about it and you're like why are
you thinking about it like stuff helps
to [ __ ] lure some of those themes along
the show I was page gets more famous and
makes a decision
the her fans doing for somebody
[Music]